Merhaba. Geçen hafta yayınladığım 81
nolu Passive Voice videomda
İngilizcedeki edilgenlik konusuna giriş
yapmış ve edilgen cümle kurmayile ilgili
ilk beş konuya değinmiştim. Eğer o
videoyu izlemediyseniz bu videoya
başlamadan önce mutlaka o videoyu
izlemenizi öneririm. Çünkü bu videoda
edilgen cümlelerle ilgili biraz daha
detay konulara değineceğim. İlk videoya
gitmek için bu videonun açıklamalar
kısmındaki linki kullanabilirsiniz.
Şimdi kaldığımız yerden yani 6. bölümden
devam ediyorum.
6. Edat alan fiiller nasıl edilgen
yapılır? Hatırlarsanız bazı fiillerin
kendilerine özgü edatları olduğundan
bahsetmiştim ve nesne ile fiilin arasına
bu edatları yerleştiriyorduk.
Look at the car, wait for the bus,
listen to the music gibi yapılar bunlara
örnek. İşte bu tür yapıları edilgene
çevirirken nasıl olsa cümlemizin nesnesi
özneye dönüşüp edilgen cümlenin başına
geçti ve fiilden sonra gelen bir
sözcükte kalmadı diyerek edatı
getirmemezlik yapmıyoruz. Örneklere
bakalım.
They were looking for him. Onu
arıyorlardı.
He was being looked for. Aranıyordu.
They insisted on this plan.
Bu plan üzerinde ısrar ettiler. This
plan was insisted on. Bu plan üzerinde
ısrar edildi.
Yani artık yanında nesnesi olmasa bile
edatımız edilgen cümleye de geliyor. Bir
de son örnekte görebileceğiniz gibi
cümlemizin nesnesi her zaman tek
kelimeden oluşmak zorunda değil. This
plan yapısını nesnemiz olarak kabul
ediyoruz ve bir bütün olarak cümlenin
başına taşıyoruz.
Days of a man with a long bird gibi bir
cümlede de uzun sakallı adamı sakalından
tutup bir bütün halinde edilgen cümlenin
başına çekiyoruz.
A man with a long bird was seen. Uzun
sakallı bir adam görüldü.
7. Belgesiz zamirlerle edilgen cümle
nasıl kurulur? Aslında indefinite
pronoun anlarla da yine aynı kurallara
göre edilgen cümleler kuruyoruz. Ancak
62. derste de öğrendiğimiz gibi any
kelimesiyle başlayanları özne konumunda
kullanamadığımız için olumsuz cümlelerde
bunların no ile başlayan versiyonlarını
tercih ediyoruz. Mesela şöyle bir
cümlemiz olsun ve biz bunu passive voice
olarak söylemeye çalışalım.
I don't understand anything says.
Söylediği hiçbir şeyi anlamıyorum.
Söylediği hiçbir şey anlaşılmıyor derken
özne konumuna geleceği için anything
değil nothing kullanacağız.
Burada
meşgul burada rızgınlık yapıyor.
Hatta bu durum olumsuz cümlede tek
başına any sözcüğü için bile böyle ve
bunun yerine de yine hiç anlamını veren
no kelimesini tercih ediyoruz. We didn't
buy any books. Hiç kitap satın almadık.
No books about. Hiç kitap satın
alınmadı.
En iyi ile başlayanlar soru cümlesinde
kullanıldıklarında ise edilgene
çevirirken herhangi bir değişiklik
yapmaya gerek kalmıyor.
Anybody at the house? Evde kimseyi
gördün mü? Was anybody at the house?
Evde kimse görüldü mü?
Eğer etken cümlemizin öznesi bir
indefinite pronouns ise bu cümleleri
edilgene çevirirken genellikle bu özneyi
söylemeyiz. Şu örneğe bakın. Nobody has
found a treatment for the cancer yet.
Henüz hiç kimse kanserin tedavisini
bulamadı.
A treatment for the cancer hasn't been
found yet.
Ancak başında no bulunan bir indefinite
pronoun kullanarak bu cümlenin
alternatifini kurmak istersek söylemek
zorunda kalırız. Çünkü söylemezsek
cümlemiz olumlu cümle gibi algılanır.
Nobody
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
8. İki fiilli cümleler nasıl edilgen
yapılır?
Bazı cümlelerde birden fazla fiil yan
yana gelmiş olabilir ve bu cümleleri
edilgene çevirmemiz gerekebilir. Bu
durumda yan yana gelen fiillerden
ilkinin mı yoksa infinitive mi olduğuna
bağlı olarak hareket ediyoruz. Bu
kavramlar sizin için bir şey ifade
etmiyorsa Jerence Infinitives konusunu
anlattığım 72. derse bakabilirsiniz.
Eğer ilk fiilimiz kendisinden sonraki
fiile ink takısı aldıran jarent bir
fiilse being art fiil 3 yapısını
kullanıyoruz.
Örneğin yaşımın sorulmasından hoşlanmam
gibi edilgen bir cümleyi İngilizcede
kurmaya çalışalım. Önce temel cümleyi
kurarak hoşlanmam dememiz gerekiyor. I
don't enjoy. Yan cümlemiz olan yaşımın
sorulması kısmındaki edilgenliği
verirken de enjoy fiilinin özellikli bir
fiil olmasından ötürü being + fiil 3
formülünü uyguluyoruz. I don't enjoy
being asked my age.
Baştaki fiilimiz kendisinden sonraki
fiilin önüne to kelimesinin gelmesini
gerektiren infinitive bir fiil olsaydı
da to be + fiil 3 formülünü uygulardık.
Örneğin herkes tarafından tanınmak
istiyor cümlesindeki istemek fiili
infinitive bir fiil olduğundan bu
formüle göre çevrilmesi gerekiyor. He
wants to be known by.
Daha da ileri gidip bu iki cümleyi
geçmişe taşıyarak yaşımın sorulmuş
olmasından hoşlanmadım ve herkes
tarafından tanınmak istiyordu demek
isteyebiliriz.
Yok hocam istemiyoruz.
İlk cümle için bir önceki derste
öğrendiğimiz ve modellarla beraber
kullanıldığında m olmak anlamını veren
have + fiil 3 yapısını kullanıyoruz.
Tabii enjoy fiilient özellikli bir fiil
olduğundan hiç gözünün yaşına bakmadan
have kelimesine bile in takısı
getirtiyor ve araya da been kelimesini
koyarak bu yapıyı edilgene çeviriyoruz.
Ortaya çıkan formül ise having been +
fiil 3 oluyor. Şöyle yani didn't enjoy
having been asked my age.
Infinitive'i kullanılan diğer örnekte
ise sadece temel cümlenin zamanını
değiştirmek yeterli oluyor. He wanted to
be known by everybody.
Bazen ise iki fiil tek bir cümlede
birleşmiş iki ayrı yan cümlenin içinde
geçebiliyor. Şu örneğe bakın. İnsanlar
onun masum olduğuna inanıyor.
People believe that he is innocent.
Birinci fiilimiz inanmak. İkinci
fiilimiz ise is haliyle gördüğümüz olmak
fiili. Bu tür cümlelerin ilk kısmında
kullanabileceğimiz fiiller sınırlı
sayıda olup inanır, düşünür, bilir,
söyler, tahmin eder gibi fiiller. Bu
cümlelerin ilk kısmını edilgene
çevirirken tıpkı Türkçede olduğu gibi
özne bizim için önem arz etmediğinden
inanılıyor diyoruz. Yani şöyle onun
masum olduğuna inanılıyor.
İnanılıyor gibi genel bir ifadeyi ikinci
cümlenin öznesini veya it öznesini
kullanarak İngilizceye iki farklı
şekilde çevirebiliyoruz.
It's believed, his believed.
Bu noktadan sonra ise yollar ayrılıyor.
İlk cümlenin devamında that, ikinci
cümlenin devamında ise to kelimesi
geliyor.
Araya that bağlacını yerleştirdiğimiz
için birinci cümlenin devamına orijinal
cümlemizi aynen alıp yazabiliriz. It's
believed that is innocent.
To masterından sonra ise fiilleri yalın
halde getirmek zorunda olduğumuzdan
orijinal cümlede is haliyle geçen olmak
fiilini özüne döndürüyoruz ve be olarak
getiriyoruz. He is believed to be.
Şimdi bir de ikinci kısmı geçmiş zamanda
olan bir cümle düşünelim. İnsanlar onun
parayı çaldığına inanmıyor.
People don't believe that stle the
money.
Onun parayı çaldığına inanılmıyor derken
de versiyonda değişen çok fazla bir şey
yok. It isn't believed that the money.
He ile başlayan cümlemiz ise şuraya
kadar aynı. Devamında ise geçmiş zaman
söz konusu olduğundan yine have fiil 3
sıralamasını izliyoruz.
9. Et görünümlü edilgenler nelerdir?
Edilgenlik İngilizcede bazı kelimelerin
içinde öylesine işlemiş durumda ki artık
o sözcüklerin birer parçası haline
gelmiş. Bu şekilde oluşturulan
sıfatların bazılarını 66. derste tanıma
şansımız olmuştu. Bunlar sonları ed
takısıyla biten sıfatlardı. Yani bir
bakıma fiilin 3üncü halinin aynı zamanda
bir sıfat olarak kullanılması gibi
düşünebiliriz bunları. Mesela sıkmak
anlamına gelen war fiilinin 3üncü hali
olan bard kelimesi sıkılmış anlamına
geliyordu.
Burada onu sıkan dış etkenler olduğu
için aslında gizli bir edilgenlik söz
konusu. Benzer şekilde evlenmek anlamına
gelen Mary fiilinin 3üncü hali olan
Married de evli anlamına geliyor. Onları
birisi evlendirdiği için bunda da gizli
bir edilgenlik saklı.
Bazı fiillerin ise normal anlamlarının
haricinde edilgen bir mesaj veren yan
anlamları olabiliyor. Örneğin kapatmak
ve açmak anlamlarına gelen open ve close
fiillerinin aynı zamanda açılmak ve
kapanmak gibi edilgen anlamları da var.
Dolayısıyla bunlarla kurulan bazı
cümleler yapı olarak olmasa da anlam
olarak edilgen olabiliyor. Şu örneğe
bakın. Most banks open at 8:30 in
Turkey. Türkiye'de birçok banka 8.30'da
30'da açılır.
Etken görünümlü edilgenler olur da
edilgen görünümlü etkenler olmaz mı? Var
elbet ama bunlar daha çok deyimleşmiş
bazı kullanımlar. Mesela İngilizcede bir
işi bitirdiğimiz zaman I have finished
my job demek yerine I finished with
my job diyoruz.
Finished building. Be finished with
edilgen gibi görünse de bitirmek
anlamına gelen etken bir ifade.
Kayboldum derken de kimse bizi kaybetmiş
olmamasına rağmen lost diyebiliyoruz.
Veya kendimiz değil de bir eşyamızı
kaybetmişsek sanki onu birileri götürmüş
gibi. It's gone. Yani gitmiş
diyebiliyoruz.
[Müzik]
10. B yerine get kullanılır mı?
Kullanılır. Caizdir ama bazı koşulları
var. Her şeyden önce bunu daha çok
konuşma dilinde tercih ediyoruz ve
beklenmedik bir şekilde aniden
gerçekleşen şeyleri anlatırken
kullanıyoruz.
Mesela terfi ettirildim derken I was
promoted yerine I got promoted
diyebiliriz.
Durum fiilleri aniden gerçekleşen şeyler
kapsamına pek girmediğinden durum
fiillerinin geçtiği cümlelerde be yerine
get kullanmak biraz tuhaf oluyor. Şuna
bakın mesela. O herkes tarafından
seviliyor. He is loved by everybody. He
gets loved by everybody.
Get ile beraber kullanıla kullanıla
zaman içinde kalıplaşmış bazı ifadelere
bakalım. Mary fiilinin alternatifi olan
get married evlenmek.
[Müzik]
Start fiilinin alternatifi olan ancak
ondan daha havalı duran get started.
Dress fiilinin alternatifi sayılabilen
ancak ondan daha sık kullanılan get
dressed giyinmek.
[Müzik]
Have a divorced ifadesinin alternatifi
olan ancak sözlü dilde ondan daha çok
kullandığımız getorced boşanmak.
Edilgen cümlelerde be fiilini taklit
eden get kelimesi bu işi o kadar
profesyonelce yapıyor ki B fiilinin
şimdiki zamanda kurduğumuz passive
cümlelerde geçen being halini bile
taklit ederek getting şekline
dönüşebiliyor. Şu örneğe bakın.
Ifed
all time, maybe time to reconsider
attitudes. Eğer sürekli eleştiriliyorsan
belki de tutumlarını gözden geçirmenin
zamanı gelmiştir.
Taklit edemediği tek şey ise be fiilinin
bein şeklinde kullanıldığı perfect
zamanlardaki hali. Yani şöyle bir
cümlede bein yerine got kullanamayız.
Her şeyle ilgilenildi.
Everything has been tak.
Everything has got taken care of.
Evet, bu konuyla ilgili olarak tüm
söyleyeceklerim bunlar. Şimdi bu derste
öğrendiklerimizin kullanıldığı film
alıntılarımız gelecek. Ardından da
çeviri ile öğren kitabımdan konuyla
ilgili alıştırmalar çözeceğiz. Kitabı
satın almak veya bu dersin yazılı
şeklini PDF dosyası olarak indirmek için
konuantanlatımı.com siteme
gidebilirsiniz.
Kendi ilinizde bir özel ders öğretmeni
arıyorsanız da özelders.com sitesine
bakabilirsiniz.
Şimdi film alıntılarımız gelsin.
[Müzik]
America is closed.
America closed. America closed. Don't
you stand there pretending to be
surprised.
My retirement become official the day
gets sworn in.
And this is a promise that comes from a
man who is stuck here. A man who may be
stuck here for the next 10 years.66
[Müzik]
will be delayed until further not.
You'll be amazed at what people leave at
airports. Come. He's very depressed and
he decides to take his own life.
But he takes six times the amount of
poison needed to do the job. I help you.
Why? Because I don't want anybody to get
hurt, Victor. This guy's very upset. He
needs to have the form signed by the
local hospital who's treating his father
and a doctor in Canada.
med unit stat
then go get lost get lost
get l
[Müzik]
şimdiöend Kendimiz bu konuyla ilgili
alıştırmalar çözeceğiz. Bunun için
çeviri ile öğreni kullanacağız. Sizden
Türkçe cümleleri İngilizceye çevirmenizi
isteyeceğim. Biraz sonra cümleleri
ekranda gördüğünüz zaman videoyu
durdurun ve kendinize 5 dakika kadar
süre tanıyın. Hazırsanız başlayalım.
[Müzik]
Bu sayfadaki cümleler kitaptakiyle aynı
sırada seçilmedi. Aralardan karışık
olarak seçtim. Farklı farklı
kullanımları görebilmenizi istedim.
Salata daha yapılmadı cümlesinde daha
kelimesiyle anlatılan şey aslında henüz
sözcüğü ve bunu da yet ile söylememiz
gerekiyor ve bunun için de present
perfect.
The salad hasn't been made yet.
Stadyum gelecek yıla kadar tamamlanmış
olacak. Burada future perfect'in pasif
bir cümlesini görüyorum. Yani will +
have + been + fiil 3 gibi bir şey
uygulamamız gerekecek.
Stadium will have been completed by next
year. O derhal hastaneye kaldırımladıydı
cümlesi 80. derste gördüğümüz
pastelserine bir örnek. Bunu da yine
model + have + been + verb işle
söylüyorduk. Model olarak ise should
kullanacağız bu cümlede. He should have
been taken to a hospital immediately.
Helikopter deneyimli bir pilot
tarafından kullanılmak zorundaydı. Yine
have toolının geçmiş zaman halinden
faydalanacağız ve dolayısıyla da b +3
yapısını izleyeceğiz devamında. The
helicopter had to be operated by an
experienced pilot. Bu mesele ile ilgili
olarak yapılabilecek bir şey var mı?
Yine bir model cümlesi. Model + b + verb
3 uyguluyoruz.
Bu tür alıştırmalar hoşunuza gittiyse
devamını çeviriyile öğren kitabında
bulabilirsiniz. Tanıtım ve satış
sayfasına gitmek için sağ üst köşedeki i
harfine tıklayabilirsiniz.
Ayrıca bu kanala yükleyeceğim yeni
videolardan haberdar olmak için sol üst
köşeye tıklayarak kanalıma abone
olabilirsiniz. İzlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim. Bir sonraki videoda görüşmek
üzere. Hoşça kalın.
[Müzik]